what's your impression of Geo when she
misses me simple I miss my papa
it's so cold here in the house I miss
him so much you know what I do when he's
not around
I bought these big fella uncle like this
oh my god he's in the water room cannot
tell you about thrill of all Oh mom I
love gorilla ma I've said in the
previous episode that I love sandwiches
and kind of what I meant by that is I
like anything with a piece of bread and
[ __ ] meat excited but not a dick but
a pause notice the sign of a great
burger place
they never mess up the patty always
medium-rare without Phil Collen video
over like 20 times and they've always
taught me to perfect your grill them all
to me and has one of the best burgers in
LA heads down
I don't give a [ __ ] what you say I know
you guys have been to the even the like
bachi burger you've been to the father's
offices [ __ ] like that I'm not saying
those burners are bad but they do not
compete with grill amaz pig champion
which is my favorite burger
i order the pig champion there every
time without fail I've had a lot of the
other burgers like the Palm Bay Lofton
etc and those are really good too but
the pick champion is just perfect so if
they have like this crispy buttery soft
like brioche bun they're paddy by the
way is the perfect ratio to bread ratio
and it's cooked always to medium-rare
like I love it has on champagne
hollandaise sauce a fried egg and some
Canadian bacon and some crispy arugula
so it just has everything that you love
about it has complex flavors but it's
not overly complex where it kind of
[ __ ] up your palate that Chris spicy
arugula kind of breaks down the the
fatty champagne hollandaise and that
fried egg inside and I just
it's the perfect bite you got the behave
it yeah
okay so the behemoth something I called
the mistake because I made a mistake of
ordering that murder before and it's
just this massive burger that's
sandwiched in between least grilled
cheese sandwiches so you get two grilled
cheese sandwiches mixed with all this
meat fat why do they taste delicious but
dude if you can finish that you're an
absolute monster
oh yeah holy guacamole
it's like watching a dinosaur eat
another dinosaur furious Pete actually
tackled that behemoth like it's nothing
and this is the first time I actually
got to see a competitive eater eat live
in front of me and it's like watching a
wolf devour carcass like it's insane
skill you're the crazy thing was I guess
a gorilla miles saw what people's do it
because obviously we were crowded around
him and we were recording what he was
doing but he just
they made him a second behemoth but this
time it was even more massive with an
extra patty more bacon more cheese and I
think he even had an extra a grilled
cheese sandwich his side and they wanted
to see if he could do it and I'm telling
you right now he but [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
of that sandwich is oh my goodness
I thought I could eat and you know what
the sat image is like I look at this man
he's eating this stuff but he doesn't
look like me
like where's his breasts where's his
rolls Oh God I work out too I don't look
like he should look like this oh yeah
I'm slightly turned on him
because I'm watching in his own sense I
was crazy what am I doing with my life
just getting News's is is the [ __ ] dude
I decided to forego other opportunities
to work on this channel with that is
probably one of the best decisions of my
life a lot of people may think like well
you know you had a chance to be on TV
well TV doesn't matter like this is
something that we built together and
they allowed me to be a part of it and
I'm really grateful for so you know
that's for you guys so I hope you guys
continue to watch it in 30hp if I'm ever
in Canada come hug me in HD anything
like that diarrhea for you that was
amazing
no it was like watching you
I'm never washing it in here and the hi
never gonna wash these hands again now
find Jack office like he Jackman